>> Okay.
Good afternoon everyone.
And welcome to the MSR AI
distinguished lecture series.
I'm delighted today
to have Yoshua Bengio,
from the University of Montreal,
as our second in
a long series of speakers.
Yoshua's immediately
recognizable as
one of the key figures
in the Deep Learning
revolution that's
taken place in
the last five years.
And so for those of you who
think he's new to the field,
just jumped in this century,
he's been at it for
more than 25 years.
In fact, I wrote down one of
his earliest papers was
something called data
driven execution of
multi-layer networks
for automatic
speech recognition,
which was published in 1988,
I believe at a AAAI.
>> That's 30 years.
>> Oh, you're right. I'm
not very good at math,
sort of soft math.
And many of the important
advances that we see
today in speech, vision, text,
and images, machine translation,
are directly attributable to
Yoshua's work and
that of his students.
And that work, that recognition
is evident in many ways.
If you start with
something like citations,
his work has been
cited last year alone,
more than 33,000 times,
that's a career for
dozens of people
and just a one year sample
of Yoshua's influence.
The other way in which
his work is felt,
is in the long stream of
algorithmic innovations
that he's had.
Most recently, they come in
the form of
unsupervised learning,
notably the work on
generative adversarial networks,
on attention models,
such as gating that's been
used for machine translation,
but really opens up
whole other doors
to using a variety of
other data structures.
And then perhaps the one
that's a little more hidden,
the form of influence
it's a little more hidden,
is his tremendous work in
education and in
supporting the community.
It comes from his textbook,
which is advertised
there, a lovely volume.
But, you note that it also has
all of the chapters online.
He's worked tirelessly to
promote new conferences
in the area,
like ICLR, develop community,
develop tools that are
broadly shared and to
educate a whole new
generation of leaders,
and I think that in
many ways may be as
lasting a legacy as
all the technical contributions.
And so today, what he's
going to talk about is
how we move on from all of
the amazing breakthroughs
that we've seen
along perceptual dimensions
and speech vision,
and to some extent language,
to go to a much
Higher-level Cognition,
which has been a pursuit that
he's been interested in for
many years since the early
PDP models and
perhaps before that.
So please join me
in welcoming Yoshua.
>> Thank you, Susan.
You hear me fine?
Yeah?
Okay.
So. Yeah. You see me fine.
So here, we have a little bug.
We're just going to.
So, thanks Susan
for the kind words.
And as you said,
I'd like us to move away
from what we're doing now,
which is great and is giving us
amazing industrial successes to
something closer
to human level AI.
And in that respect,
I think it's important
to look at the kinds
of mistakes and failures that
our current systems have.
And I spent some time
examining that.
I'm sure most of
you are aware of
the adversarial example's issue
illustrated here
from the work of
my former students
Ian Goodfellow and his
collaborators at Google Brain,
showing that if you just
change an image a little
bit in a very
purposeful for a way,
you can completely
fool a classifier,
but, if we go beyond
this sort of amazing thing,
what can we conclude
about the failures of
our current systems?
And I would say,
the strongest thing I see is,
that they are learning in
a way that exploits
superficial clues,
that help to do the task
they're asked to do.
But often, these are not
the kind of clues that
humans would consider to
be the most important,
and often these
reveal that the models
don't really capture
the underlying explanations,
the underlying nature like
the objects for example,
as we understand them,
by thinking about images
as coming from physics,
and in the 3-D world.
So, a lot of
what are we talking about
is how can we move forward
beyond this tendency
of current models to
sort of cheat by picking on
surface regularities, and
why this is important.
So we just put out
a couple of months ago,
a paper illustrating one more
time one of these bailings.
So we take Deep
Convolutional resonets
and we change something
superficial in
the data distribution,
which is the spectral
distribution in fourier space.
For example by, filtering in
fourier space the images
we take, images like these,
and in the fourier domain
we apply a mask like this,
which just smooths things out.
So in other words, we get
rid of high frequencies,
and you basically
don't see much changed.
But unfortunately, a network
train with these kinds of
images does very poorly
on these kinds of images.
And it gets even worse if you
do this kind of filtering,
where you randomly enhance or
reduce some of
the spatial frequencies,
and now you get these images
which humans would still
recognize properly,
but there some weird colors that
show up in some
places and so on.
And that completely
offsets the Neural Nets.
So if you're train
on images like these,
and then you test on
images like these,
you get really bad errors.
The error rates go.
For example, from a say,
six point five percent to
34 percent or something.
I'm not going to
explain all of these,
but basically you've
train on one of
the data sets that has
one way or the other of changing
the spec the fourier
characteristics,
and then you test on the others
and humans would
still see the objects,
which are the thing that
matter very clearly,
but those net networks
would get fulled.
You can of course, considerably
reduce those effects by training
the network on all of
these types of data,
just like you can reduce
the effect of versatile exam
of a show examples
by training with
our gestural examples.
But of course,
then there would be
something else that shows up,
because the network
probably still
didn't really capture the
object nets that
we have in mind.
So why is this important?
As we are deploying Machine
Learning in the real world,
what happens is that,
the kind of data on which
those systems will be used,
is almost for sure are
going to be statistically
different from the kind of
data on which it was trained.
And as an example of
this consider self
driving cars or vehicles,
for which would like
them to behave well in
these rare but dangerous states.
And unfortunately, with
the kind of models we have now,
train which provides learning,
if these examples are rare,
they're probably not going
to be learned very well.
And [inaudible] to
these special kinds of
domains like near
accident situations
like in the picture,
might be difficult.
So, humans are actually pretty
good at dealing with such cases.
I only had one accident
in my life, right.
And how did they do
before the accident?
And then how do
they do after that?
We'd only use
single example link.
We don't need to die
a thousand deaths to know how to
prevent dying while we drive.
What's the catch here?
My intuition about
this is very simple.
We have a mental model
that captures
the explanatory factors
of our world to some extent.
It's not perfect.
And we can generalize to
new configurations of
the existing factor.
We already know about trucks and
cars and the physics
of objects and driving.
And we already know about
social behavior and all kinds
of general knowledge that
allow us to intuitively
know quickly what's
the right thing to do,
and many new situations
completely different
from those we've seen.
Because they involve concepts
that we already know,
they just combine
in very new ways.
Instead, our current
machine learning would
just tend to drop dead on
these statistically very
different situations.
I think we need to
make serious progress on
the ability of our models to
discover and understand
the underlying explanation,
the underlying causal
relationships so that they
can make valid predictions
in scenarios,
in situations that are very,
very far from anything
that's been seen.
And that can be important
also when you consider
machines at plan.
Because one of the reasons
we're planning is
to avoid those situations
like dying in an accident.
But if we don't have
a good way to project
ourselves into these
situations that are very,
very different from
the ones we typically see,
then we won't be
able to do that.
As I've been saying for
more than a decade now,
it's all about abstraction
and deep learning as
we conceived it
more than a decade ago,
really was about learning
multiple levels of abstraction.
And in one of the ideas
that we proposed pretty
early is it'll be nice
if we had algorithms that
can separate out
these explanatory factors.
The phrase we use is
disentangle the factors
of variation.
The last NEBS there was
a workshop dedicated to
this question and it's
still not clear
exactly what it means.
But different people have
different ways of trying
to formalize this idea,
and I think we should
continue to try to do that.
This notion of
disentangling is related,
but different from
the notion of invariance,
as being a very important notion
and computer visions,
speech recognition and so on,
where we'd like to
build detectors and
features that are invariant
to the things we
don't care about.
But sensitive to the things
we do care about.
But if we're trying to
explain the world around us,
if we're trying
to build machines
that explain the world around
them that understand
their environment,
we should be prudent about
what aspects of the world
we would like our systems
to be invariant about.
Maybe we want to
capture everything.
And the most important aspect
isn't what we get rid of or not,
but rather how we can
separate the different factors
from each other.
If you're doing unsupervised
learning say with speech,
you'd like to have features that
capture the phonemes and
you'd like to have features
that capture the speaker.
And even if at the end
of the day you get rid of
the speaker ID and you only
care about what's being said,
it works if later
you decide that,
well, what you care
about is the speaker ID
then, that also works.
The other thing that
happens with disentangling
is it's going to
help us to deal with
the curse of dimensionality.
It is a good rule of
thumb to understand what
a good representation is.
The idea is when we transform
the data in the space,
machine learning becomes easier.
So, in particular,
the kind of complex
dependencies that
we see in them, say,
the pixel space will
become easy to model
maybe with linear models or
factorize models in that space.
And there are
many instances of this.
One of the early ideas
which has given rise
to a number of unsupervised
learning methods in
deep learning is that
we are going to learn
a two-way map or
gobalistic transformations
between the data space,
pixel space or whatever and
some representations space.
So, we have encoders
and decoders and by now,
everybody uses those terms.
And so, what do we want
from our encoder and what
do we want from the decoder.
Okay, so one is sort of
the inverse of the other.
But one of the early insights
from around 2010 or something,
is that what the encoder
does is take
the data distribution,
which is complicated, here is
represented as a spaghetti.
So, the set of points
corresponding say to
images is along this curve.
So we have this spaghetti
that we, of course,
we don't know where
the spaghetti is
but we'd like to
do is to flatten
the spaghetti into something
that is going to
be easy to model.
Once it's flat, then it's
like maybe a Gaussian
or something.
And predicting things in
that space become very easy.
Also, if you're able to do that,
so you know this
two-way transformation,
generating becomes
easy too because if
the manifold of points is
now almost a straight line,
then generating points in
a straight line is very easy.
And then, I apply the
inverse mapping, the decoder,
and I get points in the image
space that looks like images.
So, that's sort of
one geometric interpretation.
It also comes in with this idea
that in the high dimension,
we have what's called
Marginal independence.
In other words, I can
assemble from each
of the factors if
dimension is independently they
all depend on each other so
it's very easy to model
distribution in that space,
whereas, modeling directly in
that space is kind of hard.
So, that's one view
that's kind of
interesting that
came up pretty early.
And some of the algorithms
tried to do that explicitly.
One of the things we
did also pretty early
is think about how that
affects sampling methods.
But here, because something
on the flattened space
is easy but here,
I'm showing
sort of toy experiment
to illustrate what happens
when you do this flattening
with a very simple algorithm
for representation learning,
which from those days these
were stacks of
denoising autoencoders.
So, what we're going
to be doing is again,
we going take
the spaghetti here,
I just represented it
as a curved manifold.
And it's going to
be transformed into
the hidden unit space
into something flat.
And so, one interesting question
is how do we know
that it's flat?
So, here's a very
simple way that
you can check that
a manifold of points is flat.
You take two points
on the manifold.
So, two images and you
take their average.
So, you interpolate
between them.
And if the thing in between
looks like an image,
then it means that
the manifold is flat.
So, if you take
these two images and I
take the average
and the thing in
between is also on the manifold,
then the manifold is flat.
If it's true for
every linear combination,
then you know, everything
sits on that convex set.
But if the manifold is curved,
then the things in between
will not be on the manifold.
They will not look like images.
So, we can do that experiment.
So, we can take
like this image of
a nine and image of a three.
And if we work in pixel space
and we just do averages
linear combinations,
we get these images
which obviously,
are just pasting
a nine and three
together but don't look
like natural digits.
However, if we take the
same nine and we project
it in the representation space
of some unsupervised learner.
And then, we do the averaging
in that H-space.
And then, we take
these linear combinations
and we project them
back using the decoder.
We can look at
the corresponding images.
And what we see is that
the corresponding images
look like natural digits,
all the way along
the interpolation line.
And the two lines
here correspond
to interpolating a two-layer,
as the first layer
and the second layer.
And there's more than that,
which is that if as we
move interpolating from
this image to this image.
So now, I imagine
this curved manifold,
just for illustration
just like in the picture.
What we see is that
it's going to be nine,
nine, nine, nine,
nine and suddenly there's like
a very quick transition
where it becomes a three.
And it's all threes
up to this three.
And the junction
that is something
that's in between
a nine and a three,
but still preserves either
one's or the other's identity.
So, all of this
gives us some nice
intuitions about the geometry
behind what we'd like
to have in these
higher level spaces.
And so, there's been
a lot of work in applying
these ideas to
generative models.
As Susan mentioned, one of
the really hot family of
algorithms are these GANs
that we started off
three years ago.
And they are pretty amazing,
I'm not going to describe them.
But I think we are still far off
the mark. So, what's missing?
As I've been saying, if you
analyze the errors
made by those systems,
both for recognition
and for generation,
you can see that
they clearly don't
understand the world
in the way that we do.
And they are missing
often the point,
the crucial abstractions.
So, what's needed?
More abstract representations.
One aspect of this I think
is that our learning theories
also have to be modified.
Current machine
learning theories
anchored in the IID assumption,
assuming that
the task distribution is
going to be the same as
a training distribution.
And so we can get very
confident about our models,
but when we go out of
that assumption,
things can break down.
Somehow, humans
are able to do well
as I said earlier,
so what's missing?
So there's this idea of
learning Disentangled
Representations, and
one thing I tried to do in
a 2013 review paper on
representational learning
is present the idea that
we're not going to get very,
very good machine learning
without introducing some priors,
some assumptions
about the world.
Deep learning is starting with
an assumption that
this composition of
different layers is appropriate
for the data we want to model.
That there is some
compositionality that can be
captured with these
families of functions.
But there are many other
assumptions that are as broad,
as generic that some
of our models use,
and I think we should continue
adding more elements to
this list of priorities that
we put in our models in order
to improve a generalization,
but ideally try to do it in
a way that remains fairly
general and not
too task specific.
So, these include things
like exploiting the fact that
there are different scales,
both spatially and temporally,
and we already have
models that do that,
but I think there's a lot
more to exploit there.
I already mentioned
Marginal Independence, in
other words the idea that,
if you take the data and you
transform it into
the right space,
then all of the factors
become independent.
Something I already mentioned
earlier is this idea that,
when we move the data
in the abstract space,
the dependencies
between the factors,
the variables in that space
become really simple.
And later I'll talk to you
about the consciousness prior
which is one way
to implement this.
And then, another idea I
mentioned is that of causality.
So, I think the whole area
of causal machine learning
is still very
young and I wish
there would be
more people exploring this
because I believe this
is something that humans
take advantage of,
and it's one of the ingredients
that allows us to
generalize to these very
different scenarios.
And I'll mention
some work we started,
what I call controllable factors
in that direction.
So if we look
at how humans learn in
a very autonomous way,
like look at all the knowledge
that babies have
by two year old,
like intuitive
physics, one thing
that is interesting to consider
is how much they interact with
their environment in order
to acquire that knowledge.
And I now think that
for upcoming progress towards
human level intelligence,
machine learning needs to
move more towards this notion
that acting in the world
to acquire information is a
very, very important tool.
Humans do it and I think this
is something that we need
to pay more attention to.
And of course, the basic tools
from that come from
reinforcement learning,
but we may have to
reinvent a bit of
reinforcement learning to move
further in that direction.
So, one particular aspect that
we explored is this idea
of controllability.
I'm looking for a prop here.
Let's see. So, here's a prop.
I just made up a policy
here to control
this sheet of paper.
I can move it around in
space, I can fold it.
I can do all kinds
of fun things with
it and I just made it up.
I've made up these policies
to control different aspects
of this object.
So, what this
illustrates is that,
our brain can come up
with control policies
that influence specific
aspects of the world,
like the position of
this object and different,
complicated geometrical
attributes here about its folding.
And clearly my brain can
represent that information so,
I could report it to you,
I can tell you where it is,
I can have a mental model of it,
I can plan based on it.
And so, we have these two things
happening in parallel.
We have the representation and
the policies and they're
matched in some way.
So, I have policies to affect
one aspect of the world.
I can decide to move
just this thing and
I can represent
that thing in my mind.
So I'll tell you
more about this.
But, clearly, in order to
discover these aspects of
the world that are controllable,
which are not all the aspects
of the world but I
think they give us
very strong clues
about how the world
works, you need to be acting.
You need to be
trying things out.
And I think as you do that,
emerges almost naturally for
the learner
very important notions
from cognitive science,
like the notion of
objects and agents.
Well, the notion
of object emerges
because the objects are
the sort of aggregates
of attributes that I'm
controlling together.
I controlling x, y and z
and other attributes of
this thing and they
are all sort of spatially
coherent as well.
And that sort of
things that can be
controlled are
attributes of objects.
And agents are the entities
that can do that.
I'm an agent but I can
also see you do some things
and imagine how I would
be doing it if I were you,
or something like this.
And we do that all the time.
So, the notion of
agents is very,
very convenient to
model the world once
we incorporate of course actions
and trying to control
things in the world.
Now, there's
something particular
which sort of blew
my mind a little bit at
the beginning about
the kind of knowledge
that an agent acquires by
interacting in the world,
which is that it's not
universal knowledge, it's
subjective knowledge.
So, the policy I have
depends on my body,
and that's related to what
people call affordances.
There are things that I can do
that maybe a baby can't do.
And so we have a different
vision of the world,
a different understanding
of what can be done.
And so, this is different from
the maybe simple minded view
of AI where there is sort of
a universal truth
that all of us see and
all of us can control
our bodies and what
we are able to do,
kind of condition
our understanding of the world.
And it's kind of unfortunate
but we have to deal with that.
So, last year, we
started this project of
trying to put in
equations and algorithms
and experiments,
this idea of
controllable factors.
The idea that one way to
discover good representations,
or at least some of the factors
in a good representation,
is that we have clues
about the existence
of these factors by
the fact that we can control
those factors without changing
too many other things
in the world.
So, we designed a term
that would be added in a
training objective of a learner,
in which we say, "Let's look for
a policy that is
going to choose some actions
given some state,
such that after we apply
the policy, the state changes.
And, some feature,
K of the world changes
as much as possible."
So, the Kth policy is going
to control the Kth factor,
in the simplest way
to think about this.
So I'm going to have
policy number K,
control unit number K in
my network and you
need to change as
much as possible while the
other units are not changing,
or changing as
little as possible.
So, that's the
starting point of this.
And we can add that criterion
to whatever other criteria here,
it's a simple
reconstruction error.
So, we've been able to make
this kind of idea work on
very simple worlds for now and
still facing some
optimization difficulties
we don't completely understand.
But that in little toy
problems like this,
we learn both an encoder and
decoder that maps
from pixel space.
So this is like when we
image space into here,
a very simple 2D space
corresponding to, I mean,
it discovers that
what matters in
this world is
the position of the ball,
and the reason is
that the only actions
that the agent can do here
is move the ball around.
And so, it learns that what
matters is the position
of the ball.
And so, the encoder essentially
just learn to take
images and spit
out the position of the ball in
some funny space and
the decoder can mount back.
So if I play with the
coordinates here and then decode,
I get a new image where the ball
is in a different place.
And it turns out
we can interpret
the changes here directly
in terms of position,
and it has also separated
the changes happening in
one direction versus
the other direction.
So that's kind of nice.
You can also do things like take
two images in that world,
of course, encode them,
take the difference
between their
representations and that will
tell you basically what
actions are needed in
order to go from one to
the other because they
correspond to how much of
each of the factors you
should apply in order to
go from one to the other.
So that was like one-step
actions, one-step policies.
We've been extending this
to multi-step policies
and also generalizing from
a fixed any variable set
of factors to a common
natural set of factors.
Because if the kinds
of factors I'm talking
about are things
like positions of objects,
the problem is that
how many objects are there here?
How many objects are
there in the world?
Do I need a different neuron for
each possible object
that you could
ever see? That doesn't
make sense, right?
So instead of enumerating
all the factors,
what you'd like to do is
to have a name for factors.
And the names is going
to becoming natural,
like is going to be a vector,
an embedding. And so, yeah.
So, we're playing with
these kinds of ideas right now,
and playing the
same kinds of games.
But now, the names are vectors,
and what we're showing here are
the embeddings of the names
of factors that
the system discovers.
And here that it's
the same kind of game as before,
but now there's just
been more positions
and it discovers that
the important factors are
different positions
corresponding to
a grid space because
the world here happens
to have a grid structure.
Anyways Okay.
Yeah, I talked about this
already and time is flying.
So, let me move on to a second
type of exploration which
touches on I think
something I'd like to
revisit in our
training objectives for
improvised learning and it's
that they are all in
pixel space rather than
something like an abstract space.
So if you look, of
course at likelihood,
if you look at any kind
of reconstruction error,
if you look at even things
like gown training objectives,
they're all focused on what
is happening in what
I call pixel space,
but that would be like
acoustic space, or anything,
video space, cactus space,
whatever the data space.
So why is that a problem?
If we were able
to map the data to
this better representation as
I've been talking about then,
as I said, modeling
in that space,
planning in that space,
reasoning in that space would
be so much more convenient.
But actually, it's
a chicken-and-egg thing.
We're not going to
be given like magically
those representations,
so we'd like to have an
objective function that really
focuses on the abstract space.
And to see a little bit what
can go wrong with
our current methods,
let me share a little bit
of a couple of years of
experience with trying to
do speech synthesis
with Neural Nets.
We made a lot of progress
now to the point where
now Google is putting
those kinds of Neural Nets
into their speech synthesizer.
But, when we started
this research,
we were very
ambitious and we said,
"Okay, let's do like a pure,
hardcore improvised learning,
take hundred hours of speech,
and train a huge complicated
recurrent network to model
what speech is sequences of
16 thousand samples per
second for multiple seconds."
And what happens with
our current best models,
if they're trained in
a purely improvised way.
In other words, you
don't give them words and
phonemes is that they produce
speech that sound like someone
speaking in other
European language
if he's train on English.
But it's something
like there's no words,
this is like gibberish.
So these models capture
the texture of speech to
capture how speech sounds like,
but they failed completely to
capture the longer term
structure, the
linguistic structure.
Now, there's
a very easy fix to this,
and this is what you have in
a speech synthesis systems
and all of the systems
that people use these days,
which is used separately
train the model that,
is you use improvised learning.
You separately train
a model that goes
from phonemes to acoustics.
And from a model that just
captures the statistics of
sequences of
phonemes or in other
words, a language model.
And that works perfectly well.
Now, we can generate
unconditionally by
just first sampling a sequence
of words or a sequence
of phonemes,
and then conditioning
on that generate sounds.
So, besides the fact that we
have a fix by using
that knowledge,
I think what this
teaches us is that
our improvised learning
mechanisms have not been able to
discover something that
should be incredibly salient,
which is the presence
of phonemes
as the characteristics
of speech.
If you do like KEY means
clustering on acoustic signals,
you discover immediately
phonemes, right?
Or, at least broadly speaking,
it's very salient
statistical structure.
How is it that these models
haven't been able to discover
them and then see
that there's like this really
powerful part of the signal
which is explained by the
dependencies between phonemes?
And the reason is, I think,
simply that that part
of the signal occupies
very few bits in
the total number
of bits that isn't
the signal, right?
So, the rows in this signal is
16 thousand real
numbers per second.
How many phonemes per
second do you get?
Well, I don't know, 10,
right? or maybe 16.
So there's a factor of
a thousand in terms of
how many bits of information are
carried by the word level,
phoneme level information versus
the acoustic level information.
And the long length queue,
or any other criteria we use,
as I said earlier, they're
focusing on these details.
And so, yeah. As our models
get better and
better every year,
the approach, something at
the higher level, but
it's very painful.
Maybe we need to change
how we train these things.
So now, let me tell you about
a direction of
research that we've
started which
attempts to fix this,
and it's very much inspired
by cognitive psychology,
and very old work
actually about attention
and consciousness.
So one part of the idea is,
we want to design
objective functions,
where say, we could
have encoders,
but we don't need decoders.
Where the objective function
is going to be defined purely in
the abstract space.
That's part of it.
But there's something
else here which is,
I think fairly new and
connects with classical work
in the eye and knowledge
representation and symbolically.
So, think about your thoughts,
think about your conscious
thoughts more precisely.
What happens is, at
any particular moment,
there is something
that comes to your mind
and it's very low
dimensional, that's my claim.
You can convert that
into sounds, a sentence.
Not everything is like this.
For example, I can do visual
imagery and that's hard to
verbalize but many other things
I can verbalize.
But even if it's visual,
it's very low dimensional.
It concerns very few
aspects of the world.
So, why do we have
this thing which seems
to focus on so few aspects of
reality at a time it seems,
I used to think short
term memory is like crazy,
why is it like we can
only remember
seven things at a time?
Our brain is so big, why
would we have this limitation?
It's sounds like we
are under using
our computational capacity.
Well, so I'm claiming that
this may actually be a
prior that we use
and that potentially machine
only could use,
in order to constrain
representations.
And the prior is that,
there are, the assumption
about the world is that,
there are many important things
that can be said about
the world which can be
expressed in one sentence,
which can be expressed by
a low dimensional statement.
Which refer to
just a few variables.
And often they
are discreet those
we express in language,
sometimes they're not.
We can like draw or somehow,
use that to plan.
But they are very,
very low dimensional.
And it's not obvious,
if priori that things about
the world could be said that are
true and low dimensional.
So for example, again,
I'm using a prop.
If I try to predict
the future here,
there are many
aspects of it that
are hard for me to predict.
Like, where is it
going to land exactly?
It's very, very hard to predict,
right? It's a game.
But, I could predict that
it's going to be on the floor.
It's one bit of information.
And I can predict
that with very,
very high certainty
and a lot of what
we talk about are
these kinds of statements.
Like, if I drop the object,
it's going to end on
the floor, in this context.
So, this is the assumption
that we're trying
to encapsulate in
machine learning terms
with this consciousness
prior idea.
So, one part of it is that
we need a mechanism that's
going to select
a few relevant variables
from all of the things that we
could have access to
with our consciousness.
So, everything that
we can think we see,
everything that
we can talk about,
are the things that
we have access to from
low level perception to
very abstract things,
explaining what we're seeing.
We can come to
our consciousness.
So, we need an
attention mechanism,
in order to just pick
a few things that are going
to go to our attention,
go to our consciousness and
that's the attention mechanism.
So, we're working
with soft attention,
soft cotton based attention,
which is precisely the kind of
attention mechanism
that we introduced for
machine translation
a few years ago as Susan was
talking about and has
been amazingly successful,
not just from
Machine Translation,
but for all kinds
of applications now.
And I think we could use
the same kind of mechanisms.
And so, I've been using
the word consciousness,
but the word consciousness
is loaded with
all kinds of meanings
and we have to
be careful here
about what we mean.
So different psychologists or
philosophers are using terms
like access consciousness
or the Heyns calls it
global availability,
but basically it's
just the aspect
of consciousness that concerns
the selection of elements on
which we are focusing in
order to make a prediction,
in order to act and that we
can usually report verbally.
So, how does the content base
attention work in
machine translation?
We use that to select
representations,
a different position
in a sequence,
an input sequence
that needed to be
translated so that when we
decide on the next word
in on an R and N,
that predicts the next word in
a sequence for
the translated sentence.
We can focus on
one or a few words,
which are likely to contain
the most relevant information
for the next word to produce.
And we use an
attention mechanism,
you could think of it
like little Neutral Net,
that takes two things and input.
It takes one candidate location,
so that where we want to focus,
there are some features
that are being
computed and it takes
the current state,
which is sort of the context,
in which we are going
to take the decision
of where to focus.
It outputs a score that says,
how much we want to focus
our attention at this location.
And we're going to
compute such a score
for all the possible locations.
And then you can generalize
this idea in all kinds
of ways but this
is the heart of
what we're doing with
content based attention.
It's been used to greatly reduce
the gap between
classical machine translation,
based on engrams and
human quality translation at
least according to
human evaluation,
a statistical method
to evaluate quality.
So going back to
the consciousness Prior.
Whereas in traditional
Machine Learning
and Representation Learning,
we think of this top
level presentation
that captures all of
the factors of interests
here we're going to have
two levels of representation.
We're going to have this
very high dimensional
and conscious state,
which contains all of
the abstract representations,
but it contains everything
and not just the ones that
are coming to our mind.
Not just the ones that are
coming to our attention.
The ones that we
are focusing on at
a particular time
will be somehow
stored in this Low-dimensional
representation,
the conscious state.
And just like in
the previous slide,
we are going to have
an attention mechanism,
which decide what to
pick next to go into
the conscious state.
And you can think of it like,
it's kind of a choose
something out of
this soup of information.
And presumably, they are
all going to be recurrent,
because everything
is happening in time.
And an important
element of this is,
the reason we're doing all this,
is to put pressure
on the mapping between
input and representations,
unconscious
representation which is
like the N quarter I had before.
So that the N quarter would
learn representations,
that have the property,
that if I pick
just a few elements of it,
I can make a true statement or
very highly probable statement
about the world,
maybe a highly
probable prediction.
So yeah, the name,
the objective here is the same
as I had at the beginning.
So we are only
using all of this,
to imposing this sort
of pressure,
constraint on the
representation learner,
so that it learns
representations that have
this property that we can,
this defines a language
in which we can
say things compactly
that are true.
And each of those things
we're saying are
like just a few
variables at a time.
Another interesting
thing that happens
here and that connects to
classical AI is that we
now going to have
to represent here,
not just values of variables
but names of variables.
This is something unusual
for Neural Nets and you
start seeing things like
this and models like
neural training machine,
where we have these memory
with keys and values.
So, the reason we need to
have names of things is that,
for example, if I
make a prediction
about a future variable,
then what I'm trying to do,
what I have to story here is,
the name of the variable on
which I'm making a prediction
separate from its value
somehow, because later,
I'd like to be able to say, "Oh,
I had made a prediction
about this variable and
here's the observed value
and here was the
predict value and now,
I'm going to have to
update my parameters."
And so, if I were to mush
the names and the values, I
wouldn't be able to do that.
I need to be able to refer
to things indirectly.
We can do that with Neural Nets,
but we just have to design
them with that in mind.
So one little scenario that one
can look at is using
the conscious state to
make a prediction about
a specific variable,
using only of course
a few variables that are
part of the conscious state.
And then we could
just use a kind of
log like you would
which tells us how
good is our prediction,
weighted by on which variable
we're making prediction,
assuming we only
predict one thing at
a time in this very
simple scenario.
But just making
this weighted prediction
isn't going to be enough,
otherwise, the system would just
learn to extract variables
that are easy to predict,
but are kind of
meaningless or useless.
And there are
many such variables.
So, we are currently
exploring different training
objectives for this.
But one important idea is,
would like the representations
to have high entropy,
in other words to
preserve a lot of
information about the data.
So that's the idea of maximizing
entropy of the representation.
There's also a very old idea
which we're going to be reusing,
which is the idea of maximizing
mutual information between
past and future representations.
So Sue Becker who did her
Ph.D. with Geoff Hinton
and by the same time as me,
use these kinds of criteria to
extract features in
the spatial domain,
that had the property that there
was high mutual
information between
the value of the features
at nearby locations.
And I think this is something
that's relevant here,
for we're trying to do.
We're trying to define
a training objective for
this consciousness thing
that makes past's
conscious states
highly predictive of
future conscious states.
But not just predictive,
but also high
mutual information.
So in other words, that they
also capture a lot of
information together.
Okay. Another
potential source of
training objective
which I would like to
minimize as much as possible
but maybe we have no choice,
is not just a kind
of predictability,
but a sort of usefulness
for enforcement lining.
And so, what do we
use our thoughts for?
Well, it's very clear that
our thoughts have a very strong
influence on our actions.
So our thoughts are used
to condition our actions
and also plan our actions.
So very often we have
mental imagery and right
after we do something,
because it helps us figure
out whether it's
a good thing to do or not.
Right? So we could use
this consciousness
mechanism just
conditioning
information for policy,
and allow this not just to
make a single prediction,
but, imagine a future
with unfolding of
many time steps in the future.
A few more things
I want to close on.
I mentioned that we
don't really want to
have like a different neuron
for each factor,
we want to use this notion
of a district representation
for each factor.
So you can think
of each factor as
like a concept that we
can use language for,
and so they're going
to have an embedding.
And there's been actually
some earlier work done
by Mike Moser in the 90s
about how one could
represent discrete concepts
in a neural net,
using something
like Help field net.
So if you imagine that you
have a group of neurons
that collaborate with each
other to move together
towards a sort of stable
fixed point stable attractor,
that sort of clean up mechanism,
it is a sort of
discretization that makes a lot
of sense from base on
psychological experiments,
to explain our ability to
manipulate discrete concepts in
our mind, and take decisions.
Right. There's of course
connections between
this work and classical.
Yeah. You can think of
something like a statement
about predicting a variable
given conditioning variables as
just a connection is
the way of talking about
a classical AI rule.
Right? It doesn't have to be
a rule, it could be a fact,
it could be something about
the current scene
that we know is true,
or has a high
probability that is also
represented in
the conscious thought.
I think that this notion
of having to refer to
variables by the representation
of the variables itself,
the symbol has a name,
is something that comes
handy if you want to
implement some kind of
recursive compositional
computation which
is very common in classical AI.
And of course, this also
makes connection to language.
I'm hoping that it's
going to help to
associate perceptual words
with national language,
to ground the actual language,
and vice versa.
What I'm hoping is that
when learners that have this
kind of consciousness prior,
are learning with language and
perception that
the natural language
they're getting from
humans is going to help
the learners by giving
them hints about
the high level abstractions.
So I think when we
talk to our children,
we're giving them
hints about what are
relevant abstractions that are
useful in the world around them,
and probably accelerate
their learning in this way.
Okay. I see that
it's already 4:00.
Let me have a last slide
here about something
very different.
I think it's time
the machine learning community,
research community
starts thinking
beyond developing
the next gadget.
Of course those gadgets
are very profitable,
but there are other things
that matter in the world.
And it'd be nice if grad
students and researchers around
the world instead of
working see an image net
could work on datasets,
that if we could have good
solutions for those datasets,
could help millions of
people with medical problems,
or education problems,
or environment problems.
And I think that
organizations like
the partnership on AI,
to which Microsoft belongs
and as a founding partner,
is a kind of organization
that would fit very
well with a mandate of
making such things happen.
But more than
that, it's not just
doing machine learning
on these kinds
of AI for good applications,
it's also coordinating
this kind of work
across many companies and
labs around the world.
Because right now,
different companies
are doing things more or
less in that direction,
independently each
hoping to show off,
" Hey look. Where we are good. "
But I think we would
be all very much
more productive if we
coordinated those efforts,
if we prioritized what
could help people the most,
if we talked, if we invested in
talking to the people
in those say
poor countries who could
benefit most from this,
to understand better what
could have the greatest impact.
And if we didn't
just do that science.
But also made sure that
the grad students in
those poor countries also
learned the machine learning
that goes with it,
and maybe come
for internships in
our big labs and
go back with the State of
the art knowledge,
to their country to bring
that future wealth there,
instead of us
trying to save them.
So. Yeah. I think
there's a lot that
we can do that's
not too complicated,
that would be not just
the right thing to do,
but also would in the long
run help all of us. Thank you.
>> We have time for questions.
>> What do you think about
this inanes debate like innate.
So, human brains solve the
problem of billions of years.
>> Yes.
>> Of evolution and presumably,
there are a bunch
of the primitive
construct that you can use
as the base ingredient in
your unconscious stay, right?
So the question is that,
do you envision that we
should try to induce them
again from data or
what's the other way?
>> There are two things
we're combining already.
One is, we are using
our ingenuity and math
and insights to build
in the kind of priors,
that evolution has optimized.
And we're starting to use
the same kinds of mechanisms
as evolutionists used,
like meta-learning
and all that stuff.
So actually, my brother and I
started doing
this kind of thing in
the early 90s and just
didn't work because,
I mean, it worked on
so tiny scale that we abandoned,
because it's too
computational expensive.
But now, we're starting to have
the computational power
to do these things.
But ultimately, we also want to
understand what are
the underlying principles.
So I think we can use
computing power to do some
of that work of discovery,
but to also do it in
a way that we understand
the principles that give rise
to good Machine Learning.
>> So maybe let
me follow up with sort
of a concrete scenario.
For example, like biomedicine.
So there is a lot
of this sort of
intuitive or from experience,
I saw some of
this kind of little bit
like hand wavy reasoning
in medical decision making.
And it is actually
a very rich soul and body
of this kind of knowledge,
like all the entities,
relations and so forth.
So but, in the future obviously,
we will also have a lot
of big medical data like,
all the sensors and so forth.
The question though is,
do you envision
like we actually,
we learn all those kind
of objective phenotyping,
ignore all the prior knowledge.
Or is there some kind
of a middle ground to?
>> So there's always
a middle ground.
>> Okay.
>> But the equilibrium point is
shifting towards more data
and less human
engineered knowledge,
as we're collecting more data.
So there's always a trade off
and it depends on the quality
of the knowledge we have.
So some things are
stronger and we should always
use them and some things
are so-so and maybe data should
be able to override this.
If you look at the last 20 years
of NIPS proceedings,
it's all about specific
knowledge that people are putting
in their algorithms, right? Yes?
>> My question is about,
what makes something part
of consciousness prior?
Is this just.
>> You mean, what things come
into our consciousness or?
>> No. Like, there
is these facts in the world
or the observations.
>> Right. Right.
>> Is it just another layer of
abstraction you are
thinking about to make
the computation easier or
will it have some
special properties like,
being shared across
agents learning,
across different domains
kind of this
belonging to common sense,
belonging to what
agents share in terms of
acting in the world like
this cognitive special
properties in your mind,
shared cross
applications and agent?
>> So I think first of all,
there is a lot of
knowledge that we
have and that we are
consciously aware of,
but that is still
hard to communicate,
but a lot of what comes
to our consciences is
precisely the stuff that
we tend to communicate.
And it's interesting to
ask what about animals
which don't have language.
Do they have
something equivalent?
I think some primitive
versions of that, yes.
And we have probably a
stronger type of consciousness,
because it's enhanced through
our learning to communicate
with others using that.
But a lot of the common
sense knowledge isn't
something we are even
aware of consciously.
I think that's why
the classical AI program failed,
because we were
trying to build like
the roof of the house and
we didn't have the scaffold.
And the scaffold is perception
and the low level
understanding of the world.
So this is sort of near
the top of the house,
that I'm talking about and
it's not built yet either.
And it's connected
to reasoning and
symbolic stuff
and all that. Yes.
>> So I'm interested
in the one example,
the linearity invention in
the first half of the talk.
Like in the future space of
[inaudible] We should have [inaudible].
So does that mean like somehow
maybe imposing linearity towards
the end of the neural
network can help us to
resolve some of
robustness issues about.
>> Yes. So that's
precisely what the conscience
prior is doing.
I mean, I didn't
talk about linearity,
but if you think about,
what this equation
means, it says,
that we take the data,
we bring into this sort
of consciousness level,
this representation
level and in that space,
I'm going to have a predictor
that's very sparse,
because I just take
a few variables.
And it's also very simple.
So the neural net that
predicts this guy and this guy
is sitting on top here
and hopefully, is
very, very simple.
It's just a simple
linear logic or one MLP.
Very, very simple. Doesn't need
to be linear, it can
be whatever you want.
But the point is,
by constraining
the capacity at this level,
we are forcing
the representation to
somehow come up with those
factors, those representation,
those features that have
this property that we can now do
very simple operations
in order to predict
stuff from other stuff. Yes.
>> So kind of relates
to this question,
earlier you had a picture
a true relation to images
can you go back to that.
So you show that
in the pixel space,
interpolating images
doesn't give you
anything that make sense, but
>> Well it does make sense,
but it's not what we want.
>> So you're trying
to say we should operate
in the abstract space.
But another thing
that will give you
the same interpolation
is for example,
when you interpolate Wasserstein
distance that will also give you
something like on the top sort
of something on the bottom.
So I'm just saying-
>> What do you mean by
interpolating
the Wasserstein distance.
> There is a well
defined meaning of
very center of facts.
>> So you mean define a metric
that has the Wasserstein
distance locally.
>> So is well defined notion
to interpolate in-
>> Wait, the
Wasserstein distance
is a distance between
distributions.
So it doesn't make sense
what you're saying.
>> But in this case
you can think of
the picture as
a histogram of pixels.
>> No.
>> No, it's well defined,
it's well defined.
The purpose of this tutorial
right or the last leaves
on optimal transport.
>> Yes.
>> So I guess what I am
saying is that the structure
of this- or the subtraction
structure could be,
in fact, a different structure
from just a abstract space.
And with the Euclidean
structure on it,
it could be, actually,
a more complicated structure.
>> Oh, you're saying
we don't have to do
linear interpolation at the top.
We could do something different.
>> Yeah.
>> Sure.
>> It is not
actually worth it to
do the linear interpolation.
>> Yeah. I don't know what
the right thing but hopefully,
it's something simple that
can be learned quickly.
That is the most
important thing, right?
It doesn't mean many parameters.
That's, I think
what, for example,
allows us to do
one-shot learning
once you were presented
things in this abstract space.
Because relations are
simple and sparse, then,
a single example or
a few examples are enough
to sort of deduce
relationships that you
didn't know before.
>> Yes. I agree.
>> Yeah. That is the main
characteristic. Patrice?
>> I want to challenge a rule
that what you said about-
>> I was sure you would.
>> When you just
said about the limitation
of deep learning.
But before I do that,
I want to challenge
the first thing that you said
that humans are very
good at learning in
a unsupervised way.
So, let us take
the concept of complexity.
Did you learn complexity from
the physical world,
from your interaction?
>> No.
>> Where did you learn it?
>> Not so many years ago.
>> But, you learned
it in school, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And I think that's important
because we learn
things gradually.
>> Right.
>> And I am going to claim
that the problem with-
>> I agree.
>> Deep learning is that
the hypothesis space is fixed.
And, the way human learns is
that the grow the
hypothesis space gradually.
>> I agree.
>> And they grow it with help.
>> I don't see why you're saying
that deep learning
as that limitation.
I wrote a paper in 2009
called Curriculum Learning.
>> Yes.
>> That should be and I think
you should go back to that.
>> No.
This is all in line with that.
There is no contradiction
with what you are saying.
>> Well. So the-
>> So, one of the
early ideas was that we
gradually build new concepts.
Thanks to the concepts
we have already learned.
>> Yes.
>> And I do not see- So, here,
you think of it like I
am showing a snapshot
but in the evolution
of the learner,
presumably this space would
get richer and more abstract.
>> Right. But I think
this gradual growth of
the hypothesis space
is where we need
to focus and I think
this a very interesting things
to model but it requires-
>> But that's your focus.
You are going to
solve that problem
for us. Yes, I agree.
>> I like to,
just on that note,
you come to the idea of
theory revision, right?
As opposed to gradually
growing things,
you talked about children
having causal theories.
They often have causal
theories that are wrong.
>> Yes.
>> And you have
another example that
completely changes
the theory, right?
It is not like gradual changes
not repeated exposure.
How does that fit
into this notion of
just massive revisions of
what the underlying
representation looks like?
>> Well, I liked
that question because I
don't have the answer.
>> Yeah, you know that one?
>> Right.
So, the good news.
So, here, I mean
knowledge is at
different locations here,
but in particular, there's
the mapping to representations.
Then, there's this very
compact representation
of how the things are
related in that space
and sort of corresponding to
the set of rules
if you want, right?
And the good news is that,
the set of rules is
very easy to change.
That's where you can
do one-shot learning.
This is where you can
completely change your view on
something without having
to rewire everything.
And that's connected to
classical idea with
the idea that, "Oh,
I can keep all my
rules except they
change this one and now
my conclusion is
going to be completely
different where that
rules is relevant.".
So, by factorizing
representation
from facts and rules to
make things a little bit of,
you know, grow sketch,
I think makes it
much easier to do what
you are talking about.
Whereas, if it is sort
of hidden in the mush
of one big neural net
that does everything,
it is kind of difficult now to
change your mind about
something specific.
And the representation
is never wrong.
It's just- It might be
insufficient to generalize,
but it's never wrong. It's
just a representation.
The actual facts
are represented in
this top little set of
rules if you want so I
think it facilitates here.
Thanks for asking. I
hadn't thought about it.
>> If you want to make
a drastic change
with a few example,
you need very low capacity.
If you have high capacity-
>> That's right. That's
what I said. The top thing
has very low capacity.
It's sparse.
It only uses very few variables
and hopefully it is somethings
trivial like linear.
>> So, how is low capacity
tricked with deep learning?
>> We all know that
the deep part is
the representation, right?
I mean everything
is deep learning but
the part here that is
traditional deep learning is
the mapping from say images
or image sequences to
that representation space.
And that is where most
of the capacity is,
and that is where it's hard
to learn and that's
where we don't do
the job yet because
I think we're
not putting as much
pressure as we should
on the representation
to the abstract and
to have these- well,
easy that we can
make predictions in
that space very easily.
That is what this is saying.
Yeah.
>> So, we get that we have
a unconscious state and we
put the attention goes to
a conscious state too but make
up getting more broader concept.
So, does the unconscious state
encode all the
world information?
>> All the what?
>> All world information.
Or is it specific to the-
>> All the world information?
>> Yeah.
>> Like, for example,
colors. So, I want to paint-
>> Pretty much everything
that you can name, right?
So even low-level stuff.
If you ask me like what does
the color of that pixel,
I can like pay attention
to it and tell you.
>> So the input has to be
from different domains.
>> Yeah. It's very rich,
this unconscious state.
But mostly it is interesting
not because it has the pixels,
but because it has
the higher level things. Yeah.
>> That's it. This notion
that we can only can put
maybe save things in our memory
prove interesting that
you see this as a
good prior or not.
>> Yes.
>> Bug of our brain.
>> That's right.
>> But there's a bunch
of other things
where kind of irrational
or we're not good at
handling like vastly
different skills and
we act in kind of irrational
ways and I wonder if any of
those would also be
interesting priors for dealing
with the real world
as opposed to
seeing them as kind of
failures of our breed.
>> Well, maybe.
But I think we have
to try to think
of how they could be useful from
a machine learning point
of view and then say,
"Ah, maybe we could use this.
It's a meaningful thing
to add and not just, "Oh,
let's shoot
ourselves in the legs
because humans have
that failure as well."
>> Right. But I think
it can be useful
that the roads are
really complicated and we
need to build the- as humans,
act in that world
and we're trying to
reproduce that, right?
>> And so some of
these things might be
necessary sort of priors.
Just to be able to
learn quickly enough.
>> Right.
>> For you to
assume or, you know,
act as if you're
never going to have
to deal with things that are in
10 orders of two different
skills at the same time
for instance.
>> Yeah. But, we have
also to be careful,
not to try to
reproduce everything
that we know about
humans and the brain
because some of
these things might be
side effects of
our particular hardware or,
you know, evolution
is imperfect and,
you know, we like to
understand what we're doing.
>> Yeah.
>> Last question.
>> So, I am curious about
what you're saying about using
the low capacity
representation of the world
for causal reasoning
and reconciling that
with the fact that well,
I mean, yes we we often have
a very kind of abstract
approximate reasoning
about the world.
We know birds can fly for
example but then, oftentimes,
when you're trying to really
think through
a specific situation,
the devil is in
the details, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you think that
a good model would only use
a single layer of low
capacity information
or do you think there'd
be some range of.
>> So, I don't think that
these abstract low
dimensional thing
is the only space that
matters for reasoning.
At each time we project
ourselves in in the future,
when we think about something,
all the low level stuff is there
hidden and influencing
what's going on.
So I think that's
one reason why traditional
rule-based systems fail
because they are
an incomplete description
of what's really
going on whereas,
we are able to use
our intuition along the way,
which is hard to do with
with pure symbolic
rule-based systems.
So, by connecting
the low level stuff
with the high level stuff
and keeping them connected,
I think we can avoid that trap.
>> Please join me in
thanking Mr. Wright.